we start this noon hour with the latest
on the destiny jackson case and the man
arrested in connection to her death 8
news now spoke to the jackson family
bianca holman joining us now live in the
newsroom with more on their reaction i
can't imagine how difficult this is for
them i-team learned 21-year-old albert
montario was taken into custody in
california after a chase with police
he's charged with open murder and
robbery with the use of a deadly weapon
an arrest report says he told police
that he met destiny jackson online and
after meeting her he allegedly carjacked
and killed her
destiny jackson's family has some
clarity after their loved one was found
dead the suspect albert ontario is in
custody for homicide when we got the
news that somebody was being held
responsible for her murder
it was just
a bunch of emotions we wanted to jump
for joy we wanted to celebrate that
finally we were getting some kind of
answers but there's a wave of heaviness
knowing what happened at just 24 years
old jackson's body was found by a hiker
in the desert near sloan a day after she
was reported missing her stolen car was
spotted in southern california which is
where police say ontario confessed
during his arrest police discovered two
guns and blood splattered in the vehicle
it like shatters our hearts all over
again because it's like
you really you really stole her from us
you really stole her life with an arrest
in the case family members take one step
towards peace it's just a beginning it's
really just
this much of justice that we're looking
for
i mean how do you even answer for that
how do you deem what's enough justice
for what he did to her
now ontario also told police he shot her
three times before dumping her body
that's according to the police report
paperwork has been filed to bring him
back to las vegas to face charges bianca
holman live local now